c'est pour l'instant une guerre des
nerfs et d'image des essais de missiles
des chars d'assaut en position près de
cent cinquante mille militaires déployés
vladimir poutine met au défi son
homologue ukrainien volodimir zelensky
et les chefs occidentaux comme joe biden
et emmanuel macron mais quelles sont ses
intentions enjeu de pouvoir sur les
ambitions de pure le président russe a
d'abord une crainte majeure l'ukraine
aux portes de la russie souhaite rallier
le camp d'en face l'otan une alliance
militaire occidentale de 30 pays dont la
france les états unis pour poutine c'est
une ligne rouge dangereuse pour la
souveraineté russe
imaginons que l'ukraine soit membre de
l'otan et commencent des opérations
militaires en crimée par exemple comme
d'hab quoi on ferait la guerre à l'otan
est ce que quelqu'un a pensé à sochaux
nous on dirait que non
mais il voit plus grand et pousse ses
pions dans le monde entier
en afrique avec le groupe va teneur des
mercenaires présents en libye au mali et
en centrafrique au plus proche du
gouvernement il défend des intérêts
extérieurs de la russie ensuite au moyen
orient syrie la russie est allié de
bachar al assad hélas en échange de base
militaire navale et aérienne au bord de
la méditerranée
c'est une très très grande ambition de
la part de poutine c'est de rétablir la
russie dans un rôle de puissance
mondiale conforme son contentement
permanents du conseil de sécurité
alors comment le faire reculer l'armé
privilégiée des sanctions économiques
contre les dirigeants les oligarques que
les grandes entreprises mais pas
n'importe comment si les sanctions ne
donne pas d effet rapidement ce qui se
passe ce sont des formes de
contournement des sanctions est donc en
clair si jamais les eaux l'ia ne peuvent
pas placer leur argent dans la city à
londres iront dans d'autres territoires
la bourse de shanghai autre option
arrêter la construction de ce gazoduc
avec la russie ou bannir le pays du
système bancaire international
mais cela aurait des conséquences pour
toute l'économie mondiale